cuando pensamos en áfrica nos resulta
difícil escapar de dos ideas
preconcebidas por un lado que áfrica es
un continente condenada a la pobreza de
tierra de enfermedades hambre y
desgracias muchas desgracias por otro
solemos ver áfrica como un único
territorio integrado donde la suerte de
unos está ligada a la de otros a
nuestros ojos base un continente áfrica
da la sensación de ser simplemente un
pequeño país y desde luego pocas veces
nos damos cuenta de su colosal dimensión
porque amigos áfrica es tan grande como
toda europa eeuu india china y argentina
juntas así que dicho esto ya podéis
imaginar lo diverso que resulta este
territorio bien pues en línea con estas
ideas en el año 2010 economics calificó
a áfrica como el continente sin
esperanza pero como pasa tantas veces
los pronósticos fallaron por completo
es el día de la marmota sigue siendo
sólo una vez al año no desde que comenzó
el nuevo siglo áfrica ha habido un
auténtico despegue sobre todo los países
más pobres así si nos fijamos en los 46
países que conforman el áfrica
subsahariana sin contar sudáfrica
observamos que entre el 2000 y el 2015
registraron un crecimiento económico
anual del 6 2% lo que supone por ejemplo
más del doble que el crecimiento
registrado por latinoamérica de hecho
sin ido más lejos en 2015 5 de las 10
economías que más crecieron del mundo
fueron africanas costa de marfil etiopía
tanzania ruanda y la república
democrática del congo todas ellas
tuvieron crecimientos por encima del 7%
la república democrática del congo se
encuentra entre los 10 países del mundo
mejor valorados por sus reformas por
ejemplo sólo en 2014 se crearon más de
7000 empresas en el país y haití
y claro todo este crecimiento tiene
consecuencias sociales como vimos en un
pasado vídeo sobre la pobreza en el
mundo desde el 2000 la esperanza de vida
en áfrica ha sumado 8 años
la mortalidad infantil se ha reducido
casi a la mitad lo mismo ocurrió con el
hambre y con carácter general la pobreza
extrema ha pasado de tener una
incidencia del 58% de la población en
1999 al 35% hoy en día es verdad que aún
hay más de 420 millones de personas
sumidas en la más absoluta miseria lo
que es trágico pero por fortuna las
perspectivas son bastante positivas y os
aseguro que esa zona el mundo está
llamado a jugar un papel muy relevante
en este siglo en el clase media es la
que más está creciendo del mundo el
hecho es que áfrica ya no está
emergiendo está aquí ahora en quieres ir
now áfrica se está organizando a gran
velocidad lo que favorece la prestación
de servicios públicos y las economías de
escala pronto encontraremos muchas dudas
megápolis del mundo en este continente
quién sabe tal vez en unas pocas décadas
lagos nairobi oa que se conviertan en la
nueva shangay en nairobi no se está
construyendo el que está llamado a hacer
el rascacielos más alto de áfrica las
torres hash y en accra la capital de
ghana han construido seis centros
comerciales en sólo seis años
algo que no sería sorprendente si no
tenemos en cuenta que antes sólo había 1
además la inversión extranjera directa
ha crecido con fuerza en los últimos
años y ya casi la mitad de toda ella se
concentra en sectores que nada tienen
que ver con los recursos naturales
porque ese es otro factor clave aún con
dificultades muchos de los precios
africanos están logrando construir
economías cada vez más complejas son los
llamados leones africanos los leones
africanos kenia uganda tanzania
mozambique zambia son muchos los países
africanos que avanzan rápido y de todos
ellos hablaremos de forma específica en
el futuro pero hoy nos vamos a centrar
en los siguientes casos porque nos
parecen particularmente relevantes
ruanda
este es un país pequeñito de apenas 12
millones de habitantes y sin salida al
mar aún es muy pobre pero desde el año
2001 ha registrado un crecimiento anual
de casi el 9 por ciento y atención
hablamos de un país sin petróleo y
recursos naturales destacados como lo ha
conseguido pues fundamentalmente
apostando por favorecer la creación de
empresas de esta forma ruanda es según
el informe doing bussiness del 2016 el
segundo país del áfrica subsahariana
donde más fácil resulta hacer negocios y
también es el cuarto de la zona en el
ranking de libertad económica casualidad
pero no ahora nos estamos fijando en las
ciudades medianas si están bien
organizadas y pones todo lo que se
necesita y buenas conexiones muy
probablemente crecerán
gracias a ello casi la totalidad de los
niños cursan educación primaria y el 98%
de los ruandeses tienen ya acceso a la
sanidad lo que ha supuesto por ejemplo
que la mortalidad infantil caiga un 60
por ciento y que el sida en la malaria
hayan retrocedido de forma impresionante
por cierto paul kagamé su presidente se
declara discípulo de lee kuan yew el
legendario líder de singapur de los
álamos
etiopía
en este caso hablamos de un país mucho
más grande de casi 100 millones de
habitantes y donde por desgracia aún
cerca de 20 millones de personas tienen
problemas nutricionales sin embargo las
cosas están cambiando velozmente y hoy
su capital addis abeba es una sucesión
de obras
de hecho hace algo menos de un año se
inauguró allí el primer tren ligero de
toda la áfrica subsahariana y no es para
menos porque en los últimos 10 años
etiopía ha sido el país de áfrica que
más ha crecido su economía se ha
multiplicado por 5 en este periodo y el
crecimiento del pib real ha superado el
10% cada año el país que en la década de
los 80 fuese símbolo mundial de la
pobreza y el hambre hoy exhibe las tasas
de crecimiento más altas de áfrica
sub-sahariana y os preguntaréis cómo lo
han conseguido pues apostando por ser
más atractivos en sus vecinos para la
inversión extranjera así el país ha
fijado como prioridad tener un marco
macroeconómico estable y establecer un
marco fiscal atractivo por ejemplo las
importaciones de bienes de capital no
tienen que pagar ningún arancel y no se
aplica tampoco ningún impuesto sobre los
beneficios durante los primeros años de
actividad
sensato verdad botsuana
y no podíamos contemplar esta selección
si en este país que precisamente celebra
en 2016 el 50 aniversario de su
independencia
botsuana ha sido con mucho el caso de
mayor éxito económico de áfrica e
incluso eso de los casos de más éxito a
nivel global cuando se independizó en
1966 era uno de los diez países más
pobres del planeta y por si esto no
fuese suficiente obstáculo el país ha
aparecido desde entonces graves
problemas de sequía y además ha sido el
segundo más azotado por el vih a pesar
de ello el crecimiento ha sido tal que
hoy su pib percápita en paridad de poder
adquisitivo esto es teniendo en cuenta
los diferentes niveles de precios es
equivalente ojo al de colombia brasil o
tailandia ahí es nada en este caso la
clave del éxito como ya vimos se
encuentra la fortaleza de sus
instituciones en la prudencia
presupuestaria y en la seguridad
jurídica de hecho en el último índice de
percepción de la corrupción
botsuana aparece en el puesto 31 una
posición mejor que la de españa israel y
taiwán reformas regulatorias buen
gobierno todo ello es muy importante
porque la gente de poder abrir un
negocio
enviar sus mercancías sin que nadie le
pide un soborno o tener que contratar al
primo de moriscos pero quieres más
sorpresas bien en este continente ya hay
más de cuatrocientas empresas que
facturan cada año más de mil millones de
dólares aquí además atentos podemos
encontrar hollywood la segunda industria
cinematográfica más importante del mundo
en volumen de películas producidas cada
año con más de 2500 títulos sólo se
sitúa tras bollywood y amplia o nigeria
a cerca de un millón de personas
la gente
y por cierto áfrica es el líder mundial
en lo que a banca digital y clavos
móviles se refiere y a pesar de lo que
podríamos imaginarnos la penetración
móvil es de más del 70% y casi cinco de
cada diez habitantes son usuarios de
internet hoy en día muchos granjeros
comparten sus conocimientos a través de
sms y en la calle de ruanda se utiliza
saints motor que es algo así como la
versión holandesa de uber y claro como
hay pocos coches pues utilizan motos se
lo imaginabas es verdad aún son muchos
los retos y desafíos que áfrica tiene
por delante entre ellos consolidar el
estado de derecho reducir la pobreza y
mejorar sus infraestructuras además por
supuesto de poner fin a deleznables
dictaduras como las de angola eritrea y
guinea ecuatorial sin embargo todo
apunta a que este continente dormido
está despertando espero que este vídeo
te haya resultado interesante podrás
encontrar muchos más casos de actualidad
en nuestro canal de youtube y también
los próximos domingos en la vanguardia
un saludo y hasta la próxima